if the American people believe stupid
things they're allowed to believe stupid
things and then the intelligence
agencies are like but but we have to go
fight Putin and if the American people
are doing stupid things will fail I'm
like that's too bad a decentralized
system is better than a centralized one
and here's why if it is that 60% of the
Americans are so dumb they vote for a
dumb policy which causes problems for
this country and serious ones it is
better than if you have one crackpot who
believes tons of crackpot things and
then drives the country into the toilet
what appears to be happening now is this
country is no longer operating in a
decentralized way so we are getting
hyper centralized I ideologically driven
crackpot Decisions by the Deep state
which is destroying the country and then
in the meantime they're saying but it's
everyone else who's the problem dude let
Grandma post her stupid memes on
Facebook let people be wrong and let the
best ideas win